facebook reported their q3 earnings and
disclosed that facebook reality labs aka
oculus is spending 10 billion in 2021.
let's break it down because there's a
lot of important things going on at
facebook
they're changing their reporting
structure dramatically starting in q4 so
they let us know about that today
and they'll be reporting metrics for two
different segments this is very
reminiscent of what google did with hey
here's google the business here's
youtube and here's other bets like
self-driving waymo nest etc so
in facebook's world currently foa and
frl are the two segments foa stands for
family of apps that's facebook instagram
messenger and whatsapp all the apps you
hate the love
and then frl is a fancy
acronym for facebook reality labs it's
kind of dumb that they call it this they
should just call it oculus in my mind
that's the brand so that includes oculus
and if they ever do some sort of ar
product and so that's going to be very
interesting because i think oculus has
some limitations to it but man augmented
reality i would not be surprised if
facebook drops a surprise at some point
in the next year or two
given the amount of money they're
investing and goes head-to-head with
apple
and microsoft uh hololens and does ar
that's really for me the holy grail not
vr so here is the facebook press release
quote we expect our investment in
facebook reality labs to reduce our
overall operating profit in 2021 by
approximately 10 billion dollars this is
extraordinary let's get into their
revenue facebook revenue for q3 was 29
billion that's a 35
increase year over year that's
extraordinary
if you're above 10 20 growth year over
year at this scale
that's serious growth uh so
congratulations to the team there income
for 2021 is on pace to be
around 36 billion dollars in other words
they would make one third more in
profits if they weren't doing oculus and
that's what a lot of people on wall
street are going to be wondering just
like when amazon
invested heavily in aws
or with google investing heavily in
waymo or fiber and other projects
now here's where it gets interesting
facebook gave a wide range for q4
estimates this is the next quarter
of 31.5 to 34 billion dollars that's a
big swing right we're talking about two
and a half billion dollars here
and uh they're citing quote the
significant uncertainty we face in the
fourth quarter in light of continued
headwinds from apple's ios 14 changes
and macroeconomic and covid related
factors
now
this is super notable because apple
disclosing the app tracking stuff
and the transparency features as a risk
factor means it's a risk factor like
they wouldn't be putting it front and
center they're trying to prepare people
for bad news and i bet that bad news
continues so why is that happening apple
is trying to protect our privacy so
they're not letting uh information about
your phone be shared with these
ad networks facebook's and google's like
they used to what this means is
apple is getting to make more money
selling ads in the app store and
there's their percentage of revenue for
app installs is going to go up
for facebook and google this means
they're not going to be able to target
app installations and app installations
are a huge part of the ad ecosystem why
certain apps make a lot of money we all
know that there are certain games that
have whales in them uh certain games
that have subscriptions in them there's
a really great vibrant ecosystem
and so people will pay one dollar ten
dollars fifty dollars to get an app
installed depending on how much money
they can make from it in the future
that's why you see app ads everywhere
well facebook has been making money hand
over fest doing app ads they don't own
the app store and now
apple is basically really recapping uh
nancy kerrigan style
of facebook and it's really notable i
think
so uh but but survivable let's put it
that way like even if they lost ten
percent or five percent of their revenue
it's not going to kill the company it's
really an annoyance i think more than
anything so let's break down some more
of the metrics 97.5 of facebook's
revenue came from advertising
2.5 was classified as other though they
don't say what that means
my guess is oculus is hardware you know
beatsaber and other apps that they sell
and of course the portal the failed
horrible
you know put a uh
a a picture frame from facebook in your
house with a camera micros and a
microphone something you would never do
in a million years um one thing to note
um although advertising makes the
majority of their revenue obviously
it did triple year over year the
increase in other uh revenue so we could
see
in the future app revenue of app
installs on oculus become a bigger piece
of their revenue and that would be
pretty interesting right so let's look
at the users dows were 1.93 billion for
september 2021 that's an increase of six
percent year over year this is where it
gets interesting
so they're growing very modestly year
over year in terms of daily active users
that's dows right there's dows there's
mouse there's wows daily weekly monthly
active users
but their revenue is growing 35
year-over-year so what that means is
they're getting more money out of every
user but there's not as many customers
here that's a red flag uh not a major
red flag but
so it's not a minor one either getting
more revenue out of each customer is a
good thing that you like to see that but
seeing just really modest
growth in the user base is a major red
flag so you do want to see people
extract more value from each user but
you don't want to see anemic
year-over-year growth in the user base
so that's i think a pretty big headwind
monthly active users were 2.9 billion
during q3 that's an increase of a six
percent year-over-year and monthly
active users grew 12 previously from
2019 to 2020 so we're seeing the
a growth of users got cut in half both
in dailies and monthlies there's two
ways to look at this one way to view it
is hey maybe they're getting everybody
they've reached their natural audience
the other way is they might be losing
users and this doesn't say
exactly
how many minutes they're spending online
that would be another interesting vector
obviously they don't want to release
that but you can be sure they're
studying that internally because that
relates to all the addictive nature of
social media and their revenue so that's
another metric that we'd love to get out
of them and understand but of course
they're only going to give you the
metrics they they feel they need to
daily active people is another metric
they use
and that was 2.8 billion on average for
september 2021 that's an increase of 11
year-over-year
and that's the total amount of users
across all the facebook properties
and they define that as registered and
logged in users of facebook instagram
messenger and whatsapp and the mouse and
dao as i mentioned previously were only
for facebook right so they do have other
users the whatsapp users are probably
monetized very lightly uh i don't think
they have advertising in there yet
somebody can fact check me email
producers at this weekend startups.com
if i got that wrong but i don't think
they're monetizing whatsapp all that
much
um employee headcount
is that 68 000. that's extraordinary at
the end of september and it's an
increase of 20 year-over-year they've
got lots of people working on
the metaverse augmented reality virtual
reality virtual reality you don't see
the world at all your headset covers
your eyes
you only see the virtual world augmented
reality you see the virtual world laid
upon the real world that's the
difference between augmenting reality
and a virtual reality i think you all
know that uh revenue per employee just
back in the envelope but they're making
about 120 billion a year on a run rate
you can divide that by 68 000 people and
you get 1.7 million per employee that's
pretty staggering when you think about
it so uh facebook's revenue profits
growing significantly user-based slowing
how they're going to respond to this
you know could it be natural audience
and the way you would grow here is to
either launch a new platform like oculus
or
you could acquire things they're not
going to be allowed to acquire things
given you know all of the papers that
have been released the facebook
papers and how poorly the company's
looked at by governments around the
world who have concerns
about how facebook is impacting society
and impacting elections right so
the days of them being able to buy a
whatsapp or instagram are way over there
or oculus i don't think they would be
allowed to make any of those three
critical purchases they made
okay it's time for another r crowd deal
of the week right now you can join our
crowd's investment in symptom according
to the deal memo symptom helps companies
identify and address their biggest cyber
security vulnerabilities they use a
simple solution that can be up and
running in minutes at this year's global
infosec awards they won best cyber
security product
speaking of great products all around
the world tech companies are innovating
and driving returns for investors our
crowd analyzes many of these companies
which span the entire global private
market they select companies with the
greatest growth potential and then bring
them to you our crowd's accredited
investors have already invested over one
billion dollars in growing tech
companies 29 of those companies are
currently unicorns and many of our
crowd's members have benefited from over
40 ipos or exits so here's your cta the
old call to action if you're an
accredited investor you can join our
crowd for free at ourcrowd.com
twist and review the current deals
there's no payment involved until you
decide to invest that's ourcrowd.com
twist and sign up for free